boa tarde pessoal a idéia é sabe aquele
ditado que andava de futebol limão uma
limonada
hoje eu trouxe essa história aqui pra
vocês que envolve o otimismo e bom humor
começou o amigo gabriel quando em 2011
ele foi diagnosticado com câncer passou
pelo tratamento de quimioterapia só que
o tratamento não foi tão eficaz e ele
teve que passar por um transplante de
medula né
o gabriel conseguiu uma doadora e com
isso ele criou um blog e começou a
escrever sobre como era o dia a dia do
paciente que estava passando por aquela
situação é um blog é um transplantando
ponto org e com isso gabriel começou a
atingir algumas pessoas e tal
pouco antes do transplante acontecer uma
notícia que ninguém esperava
a doadora foi negativado pelo redone
quem não sabe o retorno órgão que
regulamenta todo esse processo aqui no
brasil da doação de medula e aí que eu
entro na história oral em são paulo e de
repente na minha timeline sob a carga o
gabriel pedindo ajuda pra pra que as
pessoas se mobilizassem pra encontrar
uma nova doadora e como estava muito
perto do do transplante era altíssima o
apelido gabriel é salsichão uma grana um
alto etc
e eu sou engenheiro civil e além disso o
cartunista
então por que não a gente pegar o
salsicha do scooby-doo apa cabeça dele e
juntá a turma dele pra resolver
o espectador é secreta não é isso foi um
desenho que é o físi nós compartilhamos
no facebook e nós amigos começaram a
trocar a capa do do facebook
um começou a movimentação do brasil pra
tentar ajudar o gabriel de alguma forma
e uma grana que eu fui para se perceber
o que está acontecendo o brasil está se
mobilizando toda a história não tenta
algo maior
foi aí que na minha mão
o gabriel virou desenho animado ea gente
fez uma charge animada onde ele cantava
paródia do show das poderosas do planeta
quer um show da medula óssea
então basicamente era ele cantando como
seria se ele conseguisse aquela doadora
e ficar civil sociais por sua vez ganhou
o brasil inteiro numa onda todo mundo
apoiando compartilhando informação e e
centra mas de alguma forma salvou
gabriel
só que no meio dessa questão de
compartilhamento vamos chamar assim essa
história pegou uma veia boa ela saiu da
minha mão em são paulo vai parar na mão
do gabriel em uberlândia o gabriel foi
parar no recife na mão da juliana ganhou
a dona de uma ong uma pessoa super
bacana da atm ou a amigos do transplante
de medula óssea
a linha compartilhou na rede dela que
foi parar em rondônia em porto velho na
mão dá lugar a galo bravo essas meninas
meio costada não pode um problema que
ela quer resolver vai atrás do porto
fica quietinho andré tadeu campeão
isso mesmo garoto e uma no interior de
rondônia e e games
um amigo do braga recebeu esta charge
15h sharja elza vamos falar um pouco
sobre sobrar eu sou uma pessoa normal
como um saudável né e ela estava
cadastrada no redome com doadora de
medula
elza mudou de de casa e acabou que nessa
mudança ela não foi isso
a alteração dos dados dela no redome é
pra quem não sabe se você for
compatível com alguém o redondo vai
demandar um programa né então se ela
mudou de casa esse telegrama poderia
nunca ter chegado para ela se ela fosse
compatível com alguém só vocês terem uma
idéia pra você achar uma pessoa
compatível é é com você pra fazer um
transplante de medula a chance é de 1
para 100 mil pessoas em todos os bancos
de medula do mundo inteiro
em outras palavras num fla-flu você tem
que encher o maracanã
em outro jogo tem que ser bom o negócio
dar certo sentia uma pessoa no mundo e
seja compatível com você
e foi aí que a doadora do gabriel que a
gente tinha perdido no começo da
história era a própria elza então pela
segunda vez a gente conseguiu encontrar
a mesma doadora não se espalharam para
pensar qualquer coisa que envolva
probabilidade de um raio na cabeça
ganhar na mega sena a galera esquece
porque a gente zerou o roller
literalmente
isso aqui foi uma coisa absurda que
aconteceu né ea hora que viu tava lá
adoro secreta ela própria elza ela foi
no redome é é atualizou os dados dela
que é usado para a então menina ali ó ea
hora que viu o menino gabriel na então
uma charge que teve que andar pelo
brasil inteiro é um chamado uma campanha
feita de uma outra forma utilizando a
tecnologia criatividade né acabou
salvando a vida de gabriel não só mais
um nasceu assim quando gabriel nasceu de
novo né
então tá lá elza do ano todo o entorno o
gabriel do outro lado não tão bonita
assim mas hoje em dia ele está bem
saudável em 100% das células da elza
então ele quase se transformou na elza
médio vez em quando ele assiste filmes
chora ele comemorativo a coisa meio
estranha a mulher dele não reclama mas
ainda não sabe né
e como o aplicativo ao todo mundo falou
quê
o timbu hoje em dia o sol mais um faz
isso exatamente né
o que nós fazemos nós pegamos pessoas
que podem doar e conectamos com pessoas
que podem receber tudo muito bonito
muito legal achei uma doadora foi lá e
dom
só que a gente descobriu a segunda parte
do problema à parte de achar a doadora
compatível entre aspas tranquila
o problema é o seguinte o número de
bolsas de sangue
uma pessoa que está passando por esse
tipo de tratamento precisa para se
manter viva por conta do número de
exames que ela está fazendo por conta do
número de transfusões e etc
então prometi por gabriel que se ele
saísse vivo dessa história eu ia chamar
os amigos ea gente é criar uma rede que
replicasse a história do gabriel como
ele saiu vivo disso eu tive que pagar
minha promessa né então foi dessa forma
e nós criamos o sal mais uma primeira
rede social de doação de sangue e medula
do brasil né então quem cansar mais hoje
faz ele conecta doadores de sangue no
brasil inteiro com pessoas que de alguma
forma não consegue ter aquele número de
doadores
eu acho que levanta a mão quem já teve
alguém internada e precisou de sangue
sabe o tanto que é difícil achar alguém
para doar tem que amar seu primo vizinho
cachorro incomodar todo mundo é o que a
gente faz
nós ouvimos as pessoas que estão à
disposição para doar o doador para
aquela pessoa certa e com isso nós e
replicamos a história do gabriel que no
caso é o transplante de medula 18 vezes
nesse um ano e pouco do sal mais um
então são 18 pessoas é que a gente
ajudou a encontrar um doador de medula
ou ajudou no processo pra acontecer
aquela doação de medula
fora os inúmeros bons instantes são
doados pela rede todo dia nós temos no
brasil inteiro em todos os estados do
país são mais de 200 campanhas etc
então só mais um faz isso dia que alguém
precisar de uma bolsa de sangue se
conecta o limão virou limonada e hoje em
dia a gente replica essa história pra
todo mundo e só isso
dentro da rede o que acontece nós temos
a personificação da causa porque quer um
problema porque que o gabriel a história
dele deu certo e às vezes a história do
zezinho da você está seguinte com a
gente assim no jornal nacional william
bonner lá no final do jornal o
hemocentro regional de uberlândia está
com o estoque brasil desde o início
desde que o mundo é mundo eu acho a
gente escuta essa história isso não
utiliza a população pra ir doar sangue
a gente percebeu entre el seikh colocou
a sua cara linda história uma história
por trás seus amigos na hora que olham
para aquela história e se mobilizam que
você não vai deixar o mínimo é a mesma
coisa muito grandes sonhos e faz o que
for para ajudar ea gente descobriu que
personificando a causa a gente conseguia
aumentar a efetividade dessa rede
então dentro do sal mas acontece isso
pessoas doando pessoas compartilhando
informação e vidas serão salvas e só é
possível por conta do poder nas redes no
nosso dia a dia né então hoje em dia as
as novas gerações nascem cada vez mais
conectadas né
o desenvolvimento de rede social as
pessoas deixaram de ser participantes de
uma ação nem elas interagem diretamente
com a ação ou com qualquer outra coisa e
dessa forma cria um fluxo muito grande
de informação podendo ajudar muita gente
né então fluxo é um movimento contínuo
movimento é sangue que corre nas nossas
veias o sangue que corre nas nossas
veias é o que é vida
então enquanto a gente conseguir gerar
o fluxo dentro da rede nós estaremos
gerando vida então num futuro que não
vemos saum mais um muito obrigado
[Aplausos]